the first audition you ever auditioned
for was the les mis tour i didn't get it
i did not get it this is when the tour
started it was the 25th anniversary tour
they announced the tour after the
concert that they held i believe it was
at the royal albert hall in england i'm
not sure though like nick jonas was
marius
and uh
and alfie beau who is a very famous
actor a very famous portrayer of jean
valjean
uh he was playing he was in it norm
lewis it was my favorite thing to ever
watch it was it was what got me into
theater was this concert but they
announced the tour the american tour
after that concert and they started
holding auditions i was seven years old
and uh
i got a call in for gavrash and i was so
i was like this is it this is my big
break
and uh i didn't get it and then they
called me were you devastated
i was horrified
really
just genuinely crushed this is before i
was able to really understand that
rejection in auditions was the common
place so you're just a little boy
experiencing it for the first time and
it's something you didn't like were you
thinking of giving up right then
no
i was just like i guess maybe i'm i must
have been but i just wanted to keep
trying and it was like that show is what
kept me
is what kept me going like i was
auditioning for a bunch of stuff a lot
of commercials a lot of theater a lot of
like not a lot of tv and movie stuff
though
it wasn't what i was going for i didn't
have to look for it i still had a lot of
problems with my teeth had a lisp i was
still like
it was it was an awkward stage for me at
the time and tv and film was not about
it i remember
it's just something you didn't think as
a child you knew innately at that young
age that there was something maybe
odd or something that was going to keep
you from doing that stuff so you you
kind of ran away from it is that what
you're saying i didn't run away from it
i i went head first because i was told
first i was told by my parents that that
was always going to be a possibility at
that point in my life before i had grown
up they didn't know how severely my
condition was going to affect me i
didn't know if i was going to have
severe issues with my back or with my
spine with my knees if it was going to
be a real challenge for me and at that
time they really prepared me for the
worse right and this is called ccd this
is the clado cranial dysplasia exactly
that's right thank you
pronunciation thank you um
but uh yeah it was that condition and
they they weren't sure how bad it was
gonna affect me at that point up to that
point it looked like it might have been
getting ready to to hit me like a truck
and uh so they were just always prepared
me for that and
i guess this is something that i didn't
realize was messed up until like now at
the time i was like i like that they're
being honest i like that they're
treating me like an adult but at the
time it was not something that a
seven-year-old should be hearing all the
time but i remember casting directors
would constantly tell me like oh kid we
love you but yeah just get those teeth
in
they would say that
yeah they say and i i expressed to them
like i was also only seven so a bunch of
seven-year-olds already have their teeth
in so i guess they assumed that it might
have just been like a regular like
missing teeth like teeth situation all
that jazz right right
i always heard him like uh get those
teeth in i'd explain the condition and
then they tell me well you're not gonna
have much luck in this industry then
they would tell you that straight up